[Music]
in a world full of violence and romance
two young lovers will hold on sorry this
doesn't feel like it fits the material
can we try some miami pentameter
where's my high school lit book let me
see here uh
a classic work of english literature of
love forbade
and youthful lives undone that's been
retold a thousand times
before but this time there are lots of
drugs and guns
romeo plus juliet shakespeare's immortal
romance set today
in fair verona now a beachside town
that looks like an ad for axe body spray
presented for the royal british crown
a modern look at the bard's classic play
baz luhrmann likes to show leo cavort
a theater kid who's crossed with michael
bay whose films have helped us write our
book reports
want something subtle try a different
film did you know that they call their
gun
swords put up they sort if you're having
trouble keeping up
here are extreme close-ups of some words
[Music]
are these shakespeare easter eggs
because i'm not enough of a nerd to get
them
or a different kind of nerd meet romeo
a boy who speaks in whispers
and does he do that leo squint you bet
every 90s girl wish that he'd kiss her
and just like them
he's always soaking wet
the exchange of thy love's faithful vow
for mine
sploosh hark an angel slash codependent
mess
it's her the 90-minute fiance she'll
show the depths to which she is obsessed
by sending paul rudd in his prime away
huge mistake girl
our heroine is not quite as complex
blankly stares as if she's in a dream
it gives you enough time to recollect
the fact that she's supposed to be
13. they fall in love while others take
the hits
so who cares if these little brats are
vibin their daddies turn verona into
she's ivanka trump he's hunter biden my
poverty but not my will
when rival families crash a costume
party the spectacle surpasses any play
when is shakespeare ever been so trippy
when is mercutio been so gay
[Music]
the capulets and montagues are a-holes
they wave their guns in public
so naughty they ride the coattails of a
famous name
much like leo's old posse when our plus
jay's love
roars into ablaze their passion thaws
their family's cold standoff
marriage sex and death all in just two
days
barely time for molly to wear off such a
tragic tale of young lives crimmed
their fake death plan goes wrong so she
takes aim
romeo's the patron saint of sims and
dies before he learns her middle name
so try to enjoy shakespeare with no
lions no really
lion king is just hamlet at this point
hollywood is barely trying
how derivative can writers get the
play's the thing but not so much this
movie
unless elizabethan troubles you watch
this film that makes it go down easy
its true home is on the cw
starring romimo claire and present
danger
the merc with the mouth hey is that
jamie kennedy
can't man ant man
and that one line you know from
westworld these
violent delights have violent ends
it's lit
roseline is about to get a wild phone
call from one of her girlfriends telling
her about the literal bullet she just
dodged
they recast pietro romeo
romeo where art thou thy romeo
what do you get when you mix bees with a
ghost
bees steven it's me
your mother suck it matt and morgan